Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.
Mickey,
what?
What do you want?
What do you mean that's wrong?
I say that in every video.
Oh,
right.
Cut.
[inaudible].
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is why does Portuguese
sound like Russian?
Yeah.
Oh,
be quiet.
So why am I even asking that question?
Well,
a lot of people hear Portuguese and it's
usually the Portuguese spoken in
Portugal rather than Brazil or elsewhere
and they think it sounds Russian or
Slavic Russian being a slavic language.
Of course,
most of the people who say this are
people who don't speak either language,
but just think that something about
Portuguese sounds Russian without really
being able to describe why.
Now I'm sure that a lot of Portuguese
speakers and Russian speakers will say
that that's ridiculous.
They sound nothing alike,
but I've even heard native speakers of
Russian say that they think Portuguese
sounds Russian and I've heard native
speakers of Polish as well say that they
think Portuguese sounds like Polish.
Let me be clear that they are not saying
that Portuguese is mutually intelligible
with Russia or with any other Slavic
language.
It's not at all.
What they do say is that if they hear
Portuguese being spoken at a distance
but they aren't close enough to hear
what's being said,
or if they're not really paying
attention to what's being said,
then they think it sounds like Russian
or Polish,
and I've heard the same thing in reverse
from European speakers of Portuguese.
If they hear Russian or another Slavic
language from a distance,
they might think that it sounds like
Portuguese,
so how can that happen?
Well,
it's because of some similar elements in
there.
Phonology,
stress,
timed languages.
One important similarity between
Portuguese and Russian is that both of
them are stressed timed languages in a
stress timed language,
the length of time between stressed
syllables remains relatively consistent
and in order to fit into that fixed time
interval,
unstressed syllables become compressed
and shortened.
This results in a lot of vowel
reduction.
European Portuguese contains quite an
extreme amount of vowel reduction.
For example,
done form.
This means I'm hungry.
You can see that the sounds old is
reduced or a Schwab and the sound is
reduced form.
Another example,
important again,
the old is reduced and a is reduced to
or basically disappears important and
there's similarly a lot of vowel
reduction in Russian.
For example,
Uber.
Look,
this word means cloud.
The off is reduced to a Schwab and old
is also reduced to a Schwab.
Another example,
subpart d,
this word means boots.
You've probably noticed the reduction in
these two vowels right here,
so buggy,
Russian and other Slavic languages also
have a lot of consonant clusters and
because of the heavy vowel reduction in
European Portuguese,
it ends up having more consonant
clusters than other romance languages.
Here's a Portuguese example.
This means to despise.
This is a consonant cluster with four
consonants which results from the
dropping of the evil app for consonants
is an extreme example,
and three is more common,
and here's a Russian example split.
This means splash.
This cluster also has four consonants,
split risk in addition to the vowel
reduction,
the stress timing results in a similar
rhythm,
a similar cadence in contrast with
stress times languages,
there are also syllable timed languages
in syllable timed languages.
Each syllable lasts for a more or less
equal duration of time.
Other romance languages are much more
syllable time to then Portuguese,
which gives it its different cadence and
it's vowel reduction.
It's interesting to note that Brazilian
Portuguese,
which has weaker stress timing than
European.
Portuguese is often said to sound more
like Spanish than European.
Portuguese does,
but there are lots of stress timed
languages including English,
and I don't hear anybody saying that
Portuguese sounds like English,
so there must be more to it than that.
Sibilance.
One feature of Russian is that sibilant
sounds are quite prominent.
Sibilance are continents that have a
hissing or hushing sound as in the
English sibilants,
SA,
chef Joe,
Joe,
Joe.
Russian features these sibilants,
sa,
Zap,
chop shop,
and Portuguese features.
These four sa Za Shock Jock Portuguese
contains frequent sibilance and
specifically has an abundance of Palo
Alto Alveolar sibilants show,
which is voiceless and Asia,
which has voiced orthographic,
s and z are rendered as shook and joe in
some contexts before a voiceless
consonant or before a pause.
Sibilance are pronounced shift.
For example,
see Dutch meaning cities,
las meaning happy in the plural form
fresh,
Trish.
This means makes three.
It'll.
This means they,
in this example,
the s becomes at the end of the word and
also notice that the reduced vowel,
a fully dropped vowel actually results
in a consonant cluster ending in ship
before I voiced consonant Asia,
for example,
meaning fortunately it's also worth
noting that the letter j and also ge
when it's pronounced as a soft g,
are also pronounced measure.
These two Russian sibilance and she have
similar sounds to Portuguese shot and
this Russian sibilant draw is similar to
Portuguese,
just they're not exactly the same.
The Portuguese ones are post Alveolar
sibilants while these Russian,
once our retroflex sibilance with a
slightly different place of
articulation,
and this one here is an lv Leo Palatal
sibilant.
This sound is also slightly different
from the Portuguese one,
but it sounds somewhat similar,
at least two people who don't use that
sound natively a moment to go.
We saw a type of consonant assimilation
in Portuguese that makes the sibilant
either voiced or voiceless depending on
what follows in Russian.
There's a similar type of assimilation
for most consonants voiced.
Consonants are pronounced as voiceless
at the end of a word or before another
voiceless consonant and voiceless
consonants are pronounced as voiced
before a voiced consonants,
for example,
in this word,
becomes voiceless and is pronounced as
look in this word becomes voiceless,
and as pronounced as to zone in this
word becomes voiced and as pronounced as
good,
so the frequent voiceless sibilant ship
at the end of words in Portuguese,
as well as the assimilation of sibilance
to the following consonant,
making them either voiceless or voiced
measure might unconsciously remind us of
the similar but more generalized pattern
in Russian.
That same pattern is also a feature of
Polish and most other Slavic languages.
With Ukrainian being a notable
exception,
palatalized consonants.
One prominent feature of Russian is a
distinction between hard consonants and
soft consonants,
which our palatalized they sound
somewhat like the consonant with a yoke
sound immediately following Portuguese
features too.
Palatal consonants.
The characters in h represent a palatal
nasal,
for example,
which we saw before.
A similar sound appears in Russian as
one of the soft consonants,
for example,
who stand yet meaning eliminate and in
Portuguese the letters l,
h stand for a palatal lateral
approximate,
for example,
could our volume again,
there's a soft consonant in Russian that
sounds similar.
For example,
these two palatal consonants alone are
not enough to make Portuguese sounds
Slavic.
After all the sounds do appearance,
some other romance languages too,
but together with the other elements,
this is one thing that contributes to
the overall slavic sound of Portuguese.
The dark l,
another phonetic feature that sounds
Slavic is the villa rised,
l of European Portuguese.
This is like the dark l sound at the end
of the word field.
Oh,
the standard elo sound in Russian is
also a dark l like this.
Here's a Portuguese example.
I'll meaning high in a tall meaning
Christmas and the Russian example,
balut meaning to swim,
Luke meaning bowl or onion,
nasal vowels and diphthongs.
I mentioned before that some people
think that Portuguese sounds like Polish
Slavic language and all of the features
that I mentioned about Russian also
applies to polish,
but Polish has one other feature in
common with Portuguese that Russian does
not.
Nasal vowels in old slavonic,
there were nasal vowels,
but in modern Slavic languages,
they have merged with oral vowels except
for in Polish.
In Portuguese there are a number of
nasal vowels and nasal diphthongs,
and in Polish there are two nasal
vowels.
This letter is pronounced own,
which sounds close to the Portuguese
nasal diphthong own,
and there's one more.
Oh,
this is the nasal e sound,
because Polish nasal vowels consist of
an oral vowel followed by a nasal semi
vowel.
They sound somewhat like nasal
diphthongs,
of which Portuguese has several.
Here's a Polish example,
meaning snake,
and here's a Portuguese example with a
similar nasal vowel.
Here's another Polish example,
meaning snakes,
and here's a Portuguese example.
So even though a Portuguese is not
closely related to Russian Polish or any
other Slavic language,
they just belong to language families
within the wider Indo European language
family.
That's their only connection.
They do share a number of phonological
features that make them sound
superficially similar to the untrained
ear,
especially from a distance or when
you're not paying attention to what's
being said.
It's not really a big deal in the grand
scheme of things,
but it raises an interesting question.
What are those features that stand out
to us and make us think that they sound
similar largely on an unconscious level?
The question of the day to speakers of
Portuguese and two speakers of Russian
Polish and other Slavic languages.
Have you ever had the impression that
Portuguese sounds Slavic?
What sounds are features might have
given you that impression and to other
people?
Does Portuguese sound Russian to you or
sounds Slavic to you?
You may not consciously know what
Russian or slavic sounds like,
but you probably associate them with
certain sounds unconsciously.
Leave your responses in the comments
down below.
Be sure to follow Lang.
Focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and once again,
thank you to all of my amazing patrion
supporters.
These are my top tier patrion supporters
right here on the screen.
Many extra special thanks to them.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is
Paul.